[موسيقى]
لذلك أصبحت هذه الزهرة مثل
الكأس المقدسة لكل ما كان ثمينًا
في العالم الطبيعي مثل
هذه الرقصة السحرية الصغيرة للحشرات التي
تحدث أمامك ،
لقد دُعيت لعمل عمل فني
للجوهر الداخلي للإرهاب جناح الاستدامة
و  لقد جئت بفكرة استخدام
زهرة اللوتس زنبق الماء لأن
هذا شيء يمثل رمزًا للانتصار
على الشدائد ، فهو ينمو من الوحل
ويصعد باتجاه الضوء
وقررت أن أقوم بتعبئة الجزء الداخلي
من زهرتي بمئات من الحشرات الصغيرة
ولكي تتنقل هذه الحشرات
الصغيرة وأن
يحتفل العمل
بالإبداع الغامض لحياة الحشرات ، فإن الأشياء
تكاد تكون غير مهمة للغاية بالنسبة لمعظمنا
بحيث لا يمكن ملاحظتها على أساس يومي
وسأفعل ذلك عن طريق استخدام
هذه التقنية  المرصد ثلاثي الأبعاد
هو وسيلة لإنشاء
الرسوم المتحركة ،
لذا فهي تشبه شكلًا من أشكال الترفيه ما قبل التلفاز
، وكنت أعرف
ذلك
في
الدوائر الخارجية للاستدامة
كان هناك الكثير من
المعلومات المقدمة عن طريق
شاشات الوسائل الرقمية والإسقاطات التي بحلول الوقت الذي
وصل فيه الأشخاص إلى الجوهر الداخلي
، ربما كانوا جاهزين
لشيء أكثر راحة ،
كان العمل
موجودًا في حالتين مختلفتين.
حالة نهارية ولها حالة ليلية
وكان هذا
شيئًا قررت إدراجه
في عنوان العمل
وهو الاعتدال والاعتدال مثل عندما تكون
فترة النهار مساوية
لفترة الليل ، فهذا النوع من هذا
الانسجام  هذا التوازن بينه في
الطبيعة والعمل نفسه يحاول
تحقيق هذا التوازن ويسعى جاهدًا
لمطالبتنا بأن هذا شيء
يجب أن نتطلع إليه نحو نوع من
التوازن داخل العالم الطبيعي
ولكني آمل أن
يأتي الناس ويرون شيئًا ما
يجدون القليل من الغموض
والفضول ويريدون البقاء لبضع
لحظات والتجول في
[موسيقى]